[Music]
welcome back to
part two of the evolution of hyrule
where we look at the overall history and
the changes in geography
of the most prominent kingdom found in
the zelda series
the kingdom of hyrule in the previous
episode we covered the unified timeline
which spans from the creation of the
world to ocarina of time
if you haven't watched part 1 i highly
recommend checking out that one first as
this episode will pick up
right after ocarina so let's dive right
back in
when we last left off we analyzed the
differences between the hyrule and
skyward sword
minish cap four swords and ocarina of
time we talked about migration
geographical renaming plate tectonics
and other aspects which could have had
an effect on the biggest changes found
in the geography
now before we can move further up the
timeline we of course have to mention
the timeline split
as most of you know after the events of
ocarina of time the chronology of the
zelda series no longer follow one set
path instead it branches off into three
different realities based on the outcome
of ocarina of time's ending
one in which link is triumphant in
defeating ganon and one where the king
of evil slays the hero in battle
additionally the branch in which he is
triumphant in turn splits into two
separate timelines because of the advent
of time travel
so this means we now have three
different hyrule's two
of which the hero of time departed from
either by death or time travel
and one in which he persisted and lived
out his life it is also from this point
that we will start to see hyrule change
much more drastically in all three
branches and this is in large part due
to the presence and
influence of ganondorf ganon today we
take a look at the downfall timeline
which follows the hero of time's defeat
this is by far the strangest timeline
branch
it is the only one that lacks any of the
mainline 3d titles and instead
is a dumping ground for the majority of
the 2d and top-down installments
so let's continue down the downfall
timeline
first up is a link to the past before we
look at the actual map we have to
mention an event which took place
between ocarina of time and a link to
the past
also known as the imprisoning war this
basically refers to the same event we
see play out in ocarina of time
where ganon is sealed inside the sacred
realm by zelda and a group known as the
six sages
the big difference being that in this
timeline branch ganon extracted the
triforce of courage from the fallen hero
and later
another piece from zelda as well before
getting sealed
his ceiling also didn't happen right
after the battle with the hero the way
we saw in ocarina but instead this
happened after a long and fierce war
between ganon
the remaining hylians and the sages
under the command of zelda who
eventually emerged
triumphant now trapped inside the sacred
realm but in possession of the full
triforce
he uses it and wishes to rule the world
transforming the sacred realm from a
paradise
into the dark world under the rule of
ganon this doesn't satisfy the king of
evil
as he seeks dominion over not just the
sacred realm but hyrule
as well which is where the events of a
link to the past pick up
where ganon uses stealth and corruption
in an attempt to break free from his
prison and conquer hyrule proper
which of course in the end gets foiled
by link who takes the triforce from
ganon and wishes for all evil done to
hyrule to be undone
as well as revert the sacred realm back
to the paradise it once was
in the previous episode we used skyward
sword map as a basis to analyze the
changes in hyrule because it's the very
first game in the chronology
since ocarina of time is the game which
all subsequent timelines stem from
it only makes sense that we use it as a
basis for all timeline branches
following that game
again if you want to know how ocarina's
rendition of hyrule came to be
check out part 1 for more details on
that so here we have ocarina of times
hyrule
and a link to the past hyrule yeah this
uh this is a tough one there are some
consistencies to be found like death
mountain still residing to the northeast
of the castle and the desert lying to
the west although
slightly more to the south southwest but
there are also some major differences
which require explanation
the lost wood suddenly lied to the
northwest whereas before it was to the
south
east kakariko village is now located to
the west right below the lost woods
instead of close to death mountain
and lake hylia all of a sudden has
shifted to the south east
we don't have a clear idea how much time
has passed between
ocarina of time and a link to the past
the opening prologue of a link to the
past which as mentioned before describes
the events taking place right after
ocarina of time
simply states long ago so at the very
least we know that enough time has
passed that the events of ocarina of
time have turned to legend
it's also obvious that despite some of
the massive differences
this is still the same hyrule from
ocarina of time and not a completely
different area like a minish cab
in that game locations like death
mountain the desert and other
recognizable landmarks were missing
but in a link to the past these
locations are present
so let's try to make a bit more sense of
it death mountain doesn't require any
explanation its location relative to the
capital of the highlands is still
consistent
found to the north east the desert no
longer being called the gerudo desert
and instead the desert of mystery can
also be easily explained
the gerudo being loyal to ganondorf were
either exiled or killed during or after
the war so the hylians likely just
renamed it to desert of mystery
since its former occupants the gerudo
are no longer living here
next is lake hylia the sudden shift to
the east of this iconic lake is a bit
harder to make sense of but
not impossible the best theory i can
come up with is that the lake dried up
over the many centuries
and a new one formed next to it there is
some evidence to support this because
if we look at the map the location where
the lake used to be is now a swamp
i believe that this swamp might be the
leftover of the lake from ocarina of
time
which could mean that the swamp palace
is actually the remnants of the water
temple which was built at the bottom of
it
meanwhile a new lake formed to the south
east which we will get into shortly as
this also ties into the lost woods
kakariko village no longer residing at
the foot of death mountain is also not
that hard to imagine
perhaps the old village from ocarina of
time was destroyed during the
imprisoning war and later rebuilt in
this new location
a fierce war can absolutely cause
changes like this
since the village was mainly occupied by
hylians it and the main capital were
probably the prime targets of ganon's
army
even the absence of the temple of time
makes sense in a way
after all its primary function was to
serve as a gateway to the sacred realm
but now that ganon has been sealed
inside it they may have felt it was best
to dismantle the temple altogether or
just like the original kakariko village
the holy site may have been destroyed in
the war as well
this also explains why the temple is
never seen again in this timeline branch
we also don't see any remnants of castle
town or lonlon ranch
instead almost all of the hylians either
live at the castle or the newly built
kakariko village and farming is also
done
inside or around this settlement which
leads me to believe that similar to the
old kakariko
castle town and the nearby ranch may
have also been destroyed during the
imprisoning war
as mentioned before the prominent hylian
settlements would have been the prime
targets during this conflict
now this is skipping ahead a little bit
but the absence of lonlon ranch in a
link to the past is
actually explained later down the line
in a link between worlds which revisits
the same rendition of hyrule found here
the owner of the milk bar states that
the milk he sells
comes from long long range this would
mean that the ranch does still exist
even in a link to the past perhaps
but resides outside of the borders of
the kingdom somewhere where that might
be
is anyone's guess but it was apparently
relocated after the war against ganon
which
is a neat little detail but it's the
lost woods that stick out like a sore
thumb
as mentioned before it used to reside to
the south east but now it's found to the
north western corner of the map
had it not been called the lost woods we
could have easily deduced that this is
simply a different forest altogether
but because it carries the same name as
the forest from ocarina of time it makes
it a bit more of a head scratcher
still the only plausible explanation i
can think of is that this is indeed a
newly discovered or newly formed forest
so then what happened to the original
lost woods you know
the one from ocarina of time which lay
to the southeast well i think this
forest is at least partly at the bottom
of this newly formed lake hylia this
might sound like a bit of a stretch but
it isn't too crazy the lost woods or
rather the farrin province as a whole
has always had a connection to water
in ocarina of time the lost woods were
directly connected to zora's river but
it goes back even further than that
all the way back to skyward sword in
fact here the province is watched over
by farren
also known as the water dragon and in
the later stages of the game she is
revealed to have flooded the entire
forest to prevent enemies from wrecking
havoc i'm not necessarily saying that it
was farron who submerged the forest in a
link to the past but it does stand as an
example that the original lost woods
is prone to flooding which could be why
there's no longer a forest to the
southeastern section of the map
additionally it's possible that there
was always a forest somewhere above the
desert
since that part of ocarina of time's
overworld was unexplored
the hylians may have wanted to keep up
with tradition and with the loss of the
original lost woods decided to give this
newly discovered forest the same name
another indication that this is not the
same lost woods from ocarina of time
is the absence of the deku tree and the
kokiri neither are ever seen again
throughout the rest of this timeline
branch which could indicate that they
were wiped out during the war and
subsequent flooding of their home
which is kind of a sad reality to think
about the master sword being in the
forest
instead of the temple of time also makes
sense after all the hero of time was
killed in this timeline branch
after his demise the fate of the sword
would have been entirely up to the sages
or the royal family
and if what we discussed before is true
and the temple of time was indeed
dismantled or destroyed they may have
felt it was best to place the legendary
blade
deep inside the forest out of sight from
the rest of hyrule
especially since the sword no longer
served as a key to the sacred realm
more details surrounding the impact of
the imprisoning war can be found when we
look at the races found in a link to the
past compared to ocarina of time
there's no real point in listing
honestly because all that is left of the
familiar faces from ocarina of time are
the hylians and the zora
the gorons have completely disappeared
from death mountain
indicating that they were either wiped
out during the war or decided to move
outside of hyrule to prevent getting
caught in the crossfire of another major
conflict the latter of which is the most
likely scenario and one we will get into
soon
as mentioned before the kokiri are gone
and the gerudo were either exiled or
killed
and although the zora are still
technically present in hyrule
you might notice a well slight
difference when compared to their
ocarina of time counterparts
i won't go into too much detail as
there's already videos out there which
theorize about the evolution of the zora
but the short version is that at some
point during the imprisoning war
the zora split into two factions some
decided to flee the kingdom along with
their guardian deity jabu jabu
others decided to stay behind and
evolved into the river zora we see in a
link to the past
hence why zora's domain no longer exists
in this timeline
well not in hyrule anyway all that
remains is zora's river which is where
the more primitive and hostile branch of
the zora still live to this day
the location of their original domain
which used to be above the original lost
woods was
abandoned and it's possible that the
hylians took this opportunity to build
the eastern palace here i mean why let a
good patch of land go to waste right
so with all that said we have ourselves
a new version of hyrule all laid out
a lot has changed since ocarina of time
and although not every explanation is
rock solid we at least have some sense
of what could have happened in the
countless years between the two games
now it might seem like i'm absolutely
crawling through this timeline since we
only just got done covering the first
game in this branch and we're already 10
plus minutes in
but things are about to speed up
significantly as many of the games
following a link to the past take place
either outside of hyrule or the exact
same hyrule as the one found here
which brings us to link's awakening this
game marks the first time in our trip
through the timeline that we play as the
same link from the previous installment
so far every game in the chronology has
taken place so long after the other that
the link from the previous adventure has
long since passed but not this time
link's awakening takes place only a few
years after a link to the past
at some point after ganna's defeat link
grew restless and decided to sail on a
solo adventure outside the borders of
hyrule in order to refine his combat
skills
where he set off to exactly is unknown
as this is never touched upon in any of
the backstories
but after having fulfilled his personal
quest he attempts to return to hyrule
via the sea
once again his vessel is struck by
lightning and he gets stranded on a
mysterious island as a result which is
where the events of the game pick up
there is very little to cover here as we
have no idea where coal and
is located relative to hyrule all we
know is that it's in the middle of a
vast sea or ocean somewhere
and of course more importantly the
island isn't even real
just a dream manifested by a sea
leviathan called the windfish
link eventually succeeds in escaping
from this dream world and
arrives back in hyrule which leads into
the oracle of ages
and oracle of seasons upon arriving back
at hyrule
link is summoned by the triforce who
requests link to help save the kingdoms
of holodrum and labrena
well request is a strong word it doesn't
seem like he had much of a choice to be
honest
he just gets sent into a portal no
questions asked
it isn't until he's already spinning
into oblivion that the triforce urges
him to quote
accept our task look at poor link over
here he doesn't know what the hell is
going on
speaking of link yes this is again the
same link from the previous two games
which at the time of this recording is
the only time in the history of the
series that we play as the same hero
for three consecutive adventures four if
you count each oracle game as a separate
quest
there is again not much to analyze in
terms of geography or history
holodrum and labruna are each separate
lands and don't belong to hyrule
labrena is ruled over by queen ambi
making this a monarchy while the only
form of leadership we see in holodram is
mayor rule which means that similar to
termina holodrum is a democracy instead
despite this these two territories do
seem to have a friendly relationship and
connection to hyrule
unlike other kingdoms or territories
like termina we find triforce imagery
here
we also find a rendition of impa who was
last seen in ocarina of time
even princess zelda herself pays a visit
to each respective land when you link
the two adventures together
this means that these territories are
not only familiar with hyrule and its
royal family it also hints
that they likely exist on the same
physical plane and not in a parallel
dimension like the sacred realm twilight
realm
termina low rule and so on this is
further evident from the presence of the
zora
and gorons holodrum features goron
mountain where they live in large
numbers
these could very well be the ancestors
of the gorons who fled hyrule around the
time of the imprisoning war
and the same thing goes for the zora who
have their own domain in labrana and
these zora resemble the ones we last saw
in ocarina of time
rather than the monsters we find in a
link to the past even jabu jabu also
last seen in ocarina of time is found
here though it is unknown if this is the
very same or just a descendant
but given the fact that oracle of aegis
features time travel
i'd say this is most likely a descendant
since jabu jabu from ocarina of time was
already an adult when we first met him
next up is a link between worlds in
terms of geography
there is again very little to talk about
not much of hyrule has changed and the
overworld is still pretty much identical
to the one from a link to the past
only around a century or so has passed
since and although the linc and zelda we
find here are descendants of the ones
from a link to the past
some have speculated that this old man
found in the game may very well be
the so-called hero of legend that being
linked from the previous three
adventures
not confirmed by the way but the
evidence is quite convincing
check out celtic's video if you want to
learn more the only significant event
that took place between the last game
and this one
is that apparently for some reason the
triforce split into three pieces again
the triforce of power again returning to
ganon even though he was seemingly
killed at the end of a link to the past
but whatever i guess he can always be
resurrected or summoned somehow
the triforce of wisdom ending up with
the new incarnation of zelda
and the triforce of courage remained in
the care of the sages and is later
bestowed upon link
the game also introduces us to yet
another parallel world named lo rule a
kingdom opposite to hyrule like a
reflection or mirrored version of the
kingdom
many initially confused loru with the
dark world from a link to the past
and who can blame them they both appear
as darker versions of hyrule and loro
even features the same overworld music
but nope they are unrelated as you may
remember the dark world was simply the
sacred realm turned evil when ganon
obtained the triforce
low rule however is a completely
different story it's a kingdom with its
own royal family
own renditions of lincoln zelda and has
its own triforce and even sacred realm
the reason why the kingdom looks so dark
and depressing is because
instead of sealing that triforce like
the hylians did they flat out destroyed
their relic altogether in hopes of
ending the endless conflicts plaguing
their kingdom
turns out that when you do this the land
slowly starts to fall into decay
other than that there isn't much to talk
about when it comes to low rule
one could speculate endlessly how this
all works in the first place
i mean the introduction of a second
triforce poses so many
questions did the three goddesses of
creation make two of them
or did loru have its own rendition of
the three goddesses does this mean that
there is now a hexa force
is it possible to possess six pieces of
the triforce
or is the lorulean version of the
triforce simply an anti-matter version
thus the very same like a shadow plus if
hyrule has an anti-matter version of
itself
do other kingdoms and locations have one
as well or the whole world for that
matter
i don't know if this is all very
confusing the more you think about it
besides this isn't relevant to this
video anyway since we are primarily
focusing on hyrule
speaking of relevancy next is triforce
heroes
now the premise is ridiculous and the
events taking
place in this game have little to no
impact on hyrule or its history
the link in this game is the same one
from a link between worlds
well three versions of him anyway which
is kinda weird
in terms of the land itself called
hightopia it was once its own kingdom
but at some point after the events of
the game lost its autonomy and was
absorbed into the kingdom of hyrule we
even know its location relative to
hyrule which is said to be above it
meaning hyrule expanded its borders to
the north during this time
one final piece of trivia that might
have some relevance is that most of the
inhabitants of hytopia have rounded ears
rather than the familiar pointy ears the
hylians have
and that the hytopians possess strong
magic wielding capabilities where have i
heard that before
never mind let's not go there what
follows after is the original legend of
zelda on the nes
which takes place a long time after the
previous games in this branch
since the game barely has any story to
speak of there isn't much trivia when it
comes to the game itself
in fact the most significant events took
place in the lead up to this installment
for whatever reason the royal family of
hyrule managed to screw up once again
and use the triforce for an unknown
cause this backfires greatly
the triforce was shattered into pieces
once again
and the once prosperous kingdom declined
and was reduced to a small regional
power
and regional power can be used very
lightly
if you thought breath of the wild had a
post-apocalyptic world the original on
the nes puts it to shame
the game features no towns no hyrule
castle and the only people still living
here are hiding in caves or underground
probably because surprise surprise ganon
is back
how what why i don't know but he's back
he still has the triforce of power and
by the time the game starts has already
kidnapped princess zelda the sole
survivor of the royal family
his goal is to locate the triforce of
wisdom which in turn was broken into
eight pieces by zelda and hidden across
the land
finally we can pull up a map again and
uh yeah
this one is a different very different
unrecognizable even whatever went down
between the last game and this
one hyrule has completely changed aside
from a large graveyard which
is obviously man-made there's no other
trace of civilization left
let alone a kingdom to speak of
furthermore all landmarks have shifted
into vastly different locations
lake hylia is now at the center of the
map death mountain is still to the north
the lost woods to the south west and
there is sort of a desert though this is
definitely not the desert of mystery
formerly known as the gerudo desert it's
on the other side of the map bordering
the mountains and is so small i'm
hard-pressed to even call it a desert to
begin with
but what is perhaps the most noticeable
about this hyrule is that for the first
time in the series the territory borders
a sea
or ocean which is an interesting detail
since historically hyrule has always
been a landlocked kingdom
not counting wind waker of course since
in that game hyrule is the ocean because
it was flooded but excluding the great
flood
none of the games we've covered so far
nor the games from other timelines sees
hyrule bordering a sea
or ocean until breath of the wild the
seaboarders reside to the east and south
of the land and we can even see that
lake hylia has a river running all the
way down south which could mean that it
is connected to the sea and thus now
a saltwater lake i've been dreading
trying to explain this game's hyrule
ever since i started this project
and honestly i can do very little other
than to say this is the very first game
in the franchise
long before there were any plans for
sequels or road maps for the rest of the
series
the sudden presence of a sea or seas
plural tells me that
half of the map is still part of the old
hyrule from a link to the past
and the other half completely new
territory since all recognizable names
are found to the west of lake hylia
any location past the east side of the
lake is not something we know from past
games and as said before we suddenly
reach a sea border this sea
could have always existed even in a link
to the past but was outside the
explorable section of that game
it could even be the very same c linked
reversed during link's awakening
and as we will soon come to find out
there is much more where that came from
when we take a look at zelda 2.
that is pretty much it for this hyrule
since there are barely any inhabitants
to speak of there's no real point in
talking about races
this land is predominantly home to
monsters now and what was left is taken
over by nature
the last thing to mention in terms of
story is that right before her capture
zelda dispatches her nurse-made impa to
look for help who ends up running into
link and the events of the game pick up
by the end link defeats ganon takes the
triforce of power from him
zelda super glues her piece of wisdom
back together and bada bing bada boom
the duo holds up the two pieces in
triumph
the end but wait two pieces of the
triforce
enter the final game in the downfall
timeline zelda 2
the adventure of link which features the
same link from the last game who is now
a young adult rather than a kid
the main goal of link's quest here is to
retrieve the final piece of the triforce
the missing piece of courage
ganon isn't actually in this game or at
least not if you're successful that is
instead ganon's minions are trying to
resurrect him by killing link and using
his blood to bring their master back
also there's another princess zelda who
actually isn't the same zelda from the
last game but rather a distant ancestor
of her who's been asleep for thousands
of years because of a spell
casted on her so there's two zeldas
living in the same time period
did i mention this timeline branch makes
very little sense
story aside though this game actually
neatly ties into its predecessor it is
here that we find out that hyrule
despite being a fallen kingdom
has actually persevered far outside of
its original borders
and it spread out onto different
continents separated by a sea or ocean
and though this map looks completely
bonkers compared to anything else we've
seen so far
the original overworld from the last
game is present on this map
right here it's a bit of a crude
depiction due to the graphics
but everything matches up it also shows
that death mountain is way
bigger than we saw previously we were
only exploring the very edge of it in
zelda one
so all this time people have been living
outside the previous overworld in newly
built towns and settlements
which explains why the overworld was so
empty and barren people had migrated to
new territories to the north and even
other continents across the seas
there is still barely any trace of an
actual kingdom
no castle or main capital anywhere all
that remains are secluded
towns which interestingly enough are all
named after various historical figures
from hyrule's distant past
most of which being the sages from
ocarina of time the town of ruto
saria darunia naburu and raru no town of
empire unfortunately that's kind of
harsh there is a town called kasuto
which is said to be named after an
unseen sage from the past
one we've never seen and likely never
will oh and there's a town called
maido as well really the guy who
constantly tried to downplay and ruin
the hero of time's mission out of pure
jealousy
that's the guy you're gonna name your
town after alright then
anyway if we would cross-reference the
map from ocarina of time and later a
link to the past to that of zelda 2 we
have zelda 1's overworld included
we can see that there is very little to
say when it comes to comparisons
by the time zelda 2 takes place the
original hyrule has long since fallen
and the population has moved out of the
borders of the original territory
in fact if we look at the scale of zelda
2's overworld map knowing that this tiny
section here is the entire world of
zelda 1
this new hyrule is actually the biggest
rendition of the land ever
spanning multiple continents a link to
the past overworld would probably fit
right here somewhere on zelda 2's
overworld so you can see just how big
this new land actually is
this land probably always existed
outside the borders of hyrule we just
never got to see it
it makes you wonder how many more
continents are out there even though
this timeline branch is kind of a
dumping
ground for many of the older games and
thus makes a lot less sense than the
other timelines in comparison
it does its name justice it's a timeline
in which hyrule started as a powerful
kingdom
and slowly declined until there was
almost nothing left of what it once was
during the era of ocarina of time
instead this brand new land exists and
we have no idea about the future because
this is the last game in this timeline
and honestly i highly doubt there will
ever be a game which details anything
about the future of this place
and that concludes the episode thank you
all for watching and i hope to see you
in the next part in which we will cover
the child timeline i hope to see you
then a big thanks to my amazing patreon
supporters and channel members
of which i have two new heroes joining
the cause say hello to fuzzy paws
and alex sands also an additional shout
out to austin u
and midnight naomi because i'm an idiot
and i accidentally used an
old version of my credits in the last
two videos so
they were left out so let it be known
they are very much appreciated too and i
will make sure to do better at keeping
my list up to date from now on
that is all for now this is dawn signing
off and
have a good one